all right welcome back John Walker Lindh
often called the American Taliban is set
to walk free from federal prison at any
moment Lindh was captured with Taliban
fighters in Afghanistan after the 9/11
attacks the California native is being
released after serving 17 years of a
20-year sentence CBS this morning lead
national correspondent David Begg know
is outside the prison in Terre Haute
Indiana where Lind is being held David
good morning Anthony good morning the
prison will tell us if he's here or out
the prison website says he is still
located inside the facility look John
Walker Lindh is getting out three years
early for good behavior and inmates who
typically exhibit good behavior serve 85
to 90 percent of their sentence but
there are some United States senators
who wrote a letter to the Board of
parole in' and prison saying you have
not told us enough information about
where you're releasing people like Lynne
when John Walker Lindh was captured in
Afghanistan in 2001 he told US forces
why he decided to join the Taliban Lindh
was interrogated by CIA officer Johnny
Mike Spann who was killed shortly
thereafter in a prison uprising Lin was
taken back to the u.s. to face charges
of conspiring to kill Spann but in a
plea bargain he only admitted to
illegally supporting the Taliban we
still feel that he is radicalized and
that releasing him into our public is a
danger to everybody Allison Spann was
just a child when her father was killed
now a CBS affiliate anchor in Biloxi
Mississippi she sent a letter to
President Trump asking him to stop Lin's
release I wanted the world to know hey
Mike Spann isn't just the first American
killed in Afghanistan this is my expand
he has a family who loves him and misses
him and we're fighting for him in 2002
Lindh told a federal judge he made a
mistake
joining the Taliban and said he never
supported terrorism in a 2007 interview
with CBS News Lynn's father
defended his son we know he's not
anti-american and we know he doesn't
have any sympathy for terrorism but
intelligence reports from 2017 say Lin
continued to advocate for global gene
while in prison there is bipartisan
concern this morning about Lynne's early
release
he is among the first of more than 100
terrorist offenders who are set to be
let go in the next five years Republican
Senator Richard Shelby and Democrat
Senator Maggie Hassan sent a joint
letter to the Bureau of Prisons
questioning whether enough is being done
to protect the American public we need
to make sure that when people are
released we've done a threat assessment
so that we can plan their release
accordingly and we need to make sure
that there is coordination with state
and local officials
so lens gonna be on a supervised release
for the next three years and the
restrictions are pretty severe get this
I'm gonna read it off to you he needs
special permission to use the Internet
if he goes online he can only
communicate in English and the device is
gonna be continuously monitored and
he'll also undergo mental health
counseling and Yale he's gonna revoke
his passport right he's got to turn it
in but here's what's interesting we were
reviewing some documents that say he
wanted to go to Puerto Rico when he got
out of prison and as we know you don't
need a passport to get to Puerto Rico so
it'll be interesting to see where he
ends up popping up yes a lot of people
will be watching can't imagine what it's
like for Allyson Spanish covering the
story on the other hand the Lin family
is adding up a different point of view
yes a lot of questions there thank you
very much David beg no